so our portfolio page is looking pretty
good especially now that we've got these
adorable little kittens here that just
make me want to sneeze I'm only sneezing
because I'm allergic to cats I mean I
think they're really cute but I can't
get too close to him without his er tech
anyways so we're in our portfolio and it
would be awesome if we could say a
little bit more about you know what we
did here and what we did here on our app
and framework but there's not a whole
lot of space for it however there's a
trick we can use we can click on it and
bring up a modal which actually has some
more information about the project this
modal is a bootstrap feature that uses
JavaScript but don't worry in order to
implement it you don't need to know any
JavaScript for this assignment I want
you to implement a modal just like the
one we have here here we are inside
bootstraps documentation for modal's
this is in the JavaScript section I'm
going to scroll down to an example
alright we've got our simple example
just like the one we saw this is the
HTML that was used to create the modal
here we have the trigger that opens up
the modal notice that it's got two
attributes we haven't seen before
data toggle and data target in this
example these attributes are attached to
a button but in our case we'll be
attaching them to the images in our
portfolio inside the instructor notes
you'll find some HTML that looks a lot
like what you see here we want you to
copy the HTML you find in your
instructors notes to your own page and
it should be inside the body of your
page not inside any divs notice here
that this HTML has an ID which in this
case is my modal you can add as many
modal's as you want just make sure each
one has its own unique ID
notice how this ID matches up with the
data target above modal's here work
because of the bootstrap min-jae's file
that you should already have in your
project go ahead and see if you can add
a modal to your page once you've
finished adding your modal click this
box to continue